you took a trip didn't you i did i did i
went up to hokkaido but
it's all good you should chill a little
vacation yeah jackson is nice
every youtuber needs a vacation every
now and again all their food
food's amazing i told you they've
optimized the food right it's good man
it's good
it's as good as everyone says it is you
should go go if you get the chance
what are some like uh like specific
dishes that you had up there that you
would recommend
to people who want to go to hokkaido
spanish anything with milk in it it's
just like the best
is does it meet the hype yes i've heard
so much about hokkaido milk and
what is what is so good about the milk
there it's like the breed of cow right i
don't know man it's just rich
it's real rich it's like full cream
right yeah and i had like a milk ice
cream i don't know me like
milk ice cream but it was just like
intense milk hit you yeah
i saw you posted a picture of like beer
ice cream as well
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah just to prove
that japan does every flavor of soft
serve i don't know why you'd ever want
beer ice cream yeah there was like ice
cream that was just
beer and i was like i mean sure i'll try
it i like both these things individually
even alcoholics are like yeah this would
be good
i can't imagine a beer flavored anything
it's aside from
beer and it tastes like ice cream yeah
what's that what's the weirdest flavor
of ice cream you've had
rum raisin i don't know how dare you
probably probably the beer right i've
normally i don't know i've had
fish ice cream before oh oh
that's just disgusting yeah it was like
a salmon ice cream
oh they just they do that [ __ ] here with
food they're like i don't care about the
boundaries
i like both these things let's make it
into food that's that's like the
equivalent of [ __ ] what's what some
americans do which like buying of
mcflurry and then just dipping it with
fries
okay which just blows my mind okay but
actually i kind of like that no
no no no what it's pretty good i went to
i i
did [ __ ] took me to a steak and shake
once which is where like
the optimal place of where you do that
and i just saw like six americans
dipping their fries
into their shakes i'm just like i can't
i can't be here i have to leave we're
living in a first world country dude
why why are you eating like this
honestly like i don't do it often but it
tastes
pretty good when i've done it you know i
don't get it it's like oh it's like a
nice
it's it's the synergy of the saltiness
of the fries i don't under the shakes
i'm like no
i don't understand why it works it just
does right it doesn't also steak and
shakes like the most depressing place in
america
like i i went to one at like midnight
because i was like yeah maybe it's
because you went at midnight
there was a dollar fifty burgers yeah
yeah yeah jesus christ i don't know yeah
you've never
you've never been to a white castle
before that's that's true i have never
been to a white castle before is is it
does it meet the hype white color what
the hype of what what i don't know
because i i
i only know white castle that one movie
right uh was it how old
harold kunma or something oh yeah yeah
yeah and
so white castle doesn't sell burgers
they sell sliders okay all right so it's
like the tiny yeah what's what's the
difference between a burger and a slide
like a mini burger
slider is just like a mini burger
apparently right i don't know where it
comes from but basically they sell
sliders instead of burgers
right but like normally right like when
you buy a slider it's like you know
you go to some american restaurants and
i like me like you know my like my
chicken parmesan sliders like that
shit's bomb don't say it like that
parmesan oh what do you say that's the
way you added the chicken parmesan
call it parmesan right yeah parmesan
parmesan
oh dude that hurts me hearing that all
right go ahead yeah anyway that chicken
like
my favorites are like chicken parmesan
sliders all right so it's like the
chicken parmesan then you put like like
some lettuce in it
it's [ __ ] nice but white castle
sliders is literally just
two soggy buns and like the thinnest
patty
in existence it's like paper thin
patties and it's like oh
that's like you can get like a pack like
a six pack of
six packs it's like a six it is it's
like they box it like a six pack of
slices for like four dollars or
something i'm just like
this is this is true depression all i
know is that everyone i know who goes
there has like the shits afterwards
oh yeah yeah yeah just like like to me
that's like
how on earth we've got to the point
where that's just an acceptable outcome
how is it how is it that like americans
have gauged like the the tastiness of
a fast food joint by how much this
stomach is just destroyed the next day
you know what people are like oh yeah
it's not a good chili's meal unless i'm
[ __ ] myself constantly the next day
i feel the same with indian though like
i i i have to destroy the toilets
sure after a good indian side i kind of
get it but at the same time i can only
do it like at most
once everything but like a burger
shouldn't do that yeah
indian i've always accepted the indian
does that yeah because of the spices
yeah
it's all the spices yeah it's just like
bread and meat what is happening
like what what what when what's the oil
yeah okay you know also the most
egregious thing that i hate they do is
that they put the grease on top of the
burgers yeah that's disgusting yeah
who did this and who who likes it
because i remember going to steak and
shake and they did this to my burger and
i was like
well i don't want this anymore why would
you do this it's like you took the worst
part of the meat which is the part that
makes you feel sick
you put it on top why i remember when i
was staying at a
sydney's like family's house in
wisconsin
and they got like a takeaway pizza joint
one day yeah and one of the big selling
points of this like takeaway pizza joint
is they had like garlic bread
and the selling point was that if you
put like a wet
a paper towel on the garlic bread it
would literally soak it
in oil and they were hyping this up to
be like
yo if you put the if there's so much oil
on this that if you put
the wet paper down it will soak it and
it'll become completely wet and i'm just
thinking
how is this a selling point why why
would i want to eat this
that's like that simpsons episode when
like homer's trying to get like so fat
that he gets like the disability like
thing
and dr nick's like grab the burger rub
it against the piece of favor
if it goes see-through you can eat it
like i thought it was like a joke i
thought it was satire
no they literally like marketed it as
this garlic bread is so oily that you
can
literally soak up an entire paper towel
i just think about it and i'm just like
i hold it in my hands and it was
literally dripping and i took one bite
and one bite was enough for me that's
like the pure survival food because the
sherman oil could like power a lamp
have you ever heard of this american bow
joint called the hardest yeah yeah of
course of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
they're [ __ ] i was watching a video
yesterday of this guy who ate the
the biggest one there which is called
the quadruple bypass burger
right and it's literally think of a big
mac but stuff
big macs yeah and it was like i already
thought that that's like 20 000 calories
as well yeah this guy like demolishes it
in five minutes i don't know how the
[ __ ] he did it
but the part that got me was he was like
all right we're getting to the bun now
uh the bun by the way is soaked in lard
i'm like you oh you shouldn't you
shouldn't so
a piece of bread should not be soaked in
anything no
nothing should be soaked in pure [ __ ]
fat yeah oh yeah also
the fries were oiled in pure lard as
well that's disgusting
like i i just get a shake on top of that
i don't understand the appeal of that
that's just ridiculous
it just sounds gross it looked gross it
looked like something out of the alien
movies like yeah
i didn't want to put that in my stomach
why do people hate their bodies like
there's there's only like some let's say
cuisines you can only enjoy when you
want to like
destroy your body and that that's
probably like 3 a.m
after like out of five guys yeah out of
five guys or like i i can never eat a
kebab sober
like something has got something has
gone wrong with me like something has
gone wrong with my life
if i'm eating a kebab and i'm and i'm
completely sorry no you know i'm hella
depressed when i'm eating a kebab for
lunch
i love a lot like a great like burger
with a bit of grease on it
yeah yeah it's just a little bit you
gotta get that yeah like sometimes you
need that but there's like there's like
clear line yeah and not even drunk me
would pass
yeah right and the heart attack grill to
me is just like there is
no reason why i would want to come here
other than to feel healthy
like like and just look yeah because any
meal you have after
going to the heart of that group you see
the other patrons
and you're like oh i'm doing pretty good
for myself hey like damn okay
maybe i haven't yet because i think the
the selling point of the heart attack
girl is that oh
first of all like when you walk in they
put on like a hospital gown on you
and they sit you in a wheelchair to like
wheel you in and
here's the kicker if you weigh over 300
pounds you get the meal for free
i feel like it should be the opposite
you should be like if it's like taxing
the bridge right if you're already fat
well you should be you should be
charging at least yeah to
force you to maintain this egregious way
i i feel like the concept of a heart
attack grill is just kind of like if you
you you hear it and you're like
this is like fiction right this is this
is from like some dystopian society
from like some george orwell like this
is how this is this is how they fatten
you up before they dispose
you watch it and you realize like most
of these people just have like trauma
like at what point do we like start
being like okay maybe it's not trauma if
he's walking into the heart attack grill
maybe that's a maybe like that's on him
you know what i mean like i think that's
going
it's like a beyond a point of like
comfort food and there's gotta be like
all right this is just his fault like
this is you know what i mean
because because these shows these videos
with like these 600 pound people do a
really [ __ ] good job
and making you feel sorry for them and
be like yo man okay yeah like his parent
died at like five yeah yeah
eating disorder for some reason for some
reason at the age of five his mom was
taking him to the heart attack grill and
that's the only way that she can
remember him
and it's like okay i get it i get it i
sympathize with you but should you yeah
it's like what if my parents were like
well they've just left me crack it's all
i've had since the age of ten would they
be like
would i be like doing crack with like
it's just comfort it's comfort food it's
comfort food
to me it's like there's a clear limit
it's the point where you got to be like
all right well
maybe i should stop feeling sorry for
you yeah that that's just
oh no i never watch those shows to like
feel sorry because i i've noticed i i
watch them and they they do a really
good job making you think damn like i
guess
yeah they set up me that's the thing
they set up the they set it up as a sob
story yeah but what you're seeing
and what you're hearing is like the
complete two different things
like i get it i get how you can gain
weight but there's like a limit
of where i think that it would go beyond
anything because some of these they're
eating like i don't know like [ __ ] 15
hot dogs in the morning
with like cheese and chili on it i'm
like yeah i think i would draw the line
i think that's right
yeah well that's the thing right it's
like the thing that surprises me more is
is not the fact that
there's you know they like complaining
about having all this weight problems
and then they proceed to eat a whole
[ __ ] box of chilis right yeah but
it's also
just the egregious amount of food that
they can somehow stomach i'm like
yeah it's just looking at it makes my
stomach it just doesn't make sense to me
and
i i feel like you must like you must
have just grown up with this and because
every time i go to america i always like
the food portions in there we've talked
about this before are massive man
i'm like i'm forced to like have to have
these massive food portions and like the
first week
[ __ ] great after after a week of
staying in america
is there a salad and i asked for the
salad and what comes
and what comes out is a [ __ ] forest
you know what i mean
like they're saying a [ __ ] salad it's
like six heads of lettuce
the amount of dressing is like the same
as the meal because it's like 1600
calories
one of my [ __ ] rabbits did you
deforest the entire amazon rainforest
just to put on my plate like this this
is the
kind of like food portions we're talking
about here it sucks man because it's
such
it's so unfair because we like if you
get fat in japan i feel like that's on
you
yeah yeah like but if you get fat in
america it's like well everything was
set up against you yeah like welcome
to the system everything was set up to
make you fat yeah yeah so it's like how
the [ __ ] it like it's not fair
which is why because like my diet in
america is awful obviously because of
the food
but like also like i get to the point
where i want to
have something but something but
something not greasy
and especially like in the midwest where
it's like you know where it's like the
countryside there's a lot less choice
and a lot less healthy choices up
as well so you're kind of forced to be
like hey you can have
you you kind of have to cook for
yourself and if you can't cook for
yourself and you're pretty much [ __ ]
yeah and that's why it's so much harder
to eat healthier over there
than it is say in like japan yeah but
but even then in america i remember
i i went to the uh to walmart and i was
like okay let's get some healthy food
and it was really hard to find like the
actual like
stuff yeah the actual healthy like stuff
and then i i go to the next
aisle there's a whole aisle this blew my
mind of hot dogs
a whole isle of hot dogs not sausages
hot dogs and i was like this is insane
i thought there was only one type of hot
dog i didn't realize that hot dogs were
any different from each other because
they all taste the same
hot dogs never taste any different do
you ever notice it when you go to your
friend's barbecue or whatever
and they give you a hot dog have you
ever been like wow this tastes different
from my hot dog no no it's always like i
put mustard on that but
yeah that's how you differentiate it
they all taste the [ __ ] sense well i
mean it's all the different like
brands yeah and somehow they had like 10
rows
on a whole aisle of hot dogs i was i was
blown away i was like this is insane
i mean i think like like there is
difference in like sometimes it's like
filled with cheese and sometimes
don't do that i don't want that really
no i like that no no no no because
because this is i like a bit of spices
because this is because this is american
cheese we're talking about yeah that's
not real cheese
if it was if it was filled with actual
like real cheese then yeah i'd be a
little more i'm pissed off that they've
managed to infiltrate japan somehow see
this whenever you get anything with
cheese on top of it here it's such a
gamble whether it's americans like
[ __ ] [ __ ] americans see this is
the advantage of not putting condiments
in everything
i can actually i can actually taste the
[ __ ] difference between a normal hot
dog and a cheese hot dog and like yes
because that is an important life skill
isn't it
yes i i know i can differentiate between
10 different brands
that's why if you just put condiments on
it all the time then it just tastes like
the condiments right you don't
you don't get to taste the sausages do
you think we're like [ __ ] drowning
out
hot dogs and sauce honestly it looks
kind of looks like it a lot of the times